good day and welcome to today's webinar
the clinical utility of one comma 25
dihydroxy vitamin d
it's my pleasure to introduce our
presenter dr gregory plotnikov
dr platnikov is a board certified
internist and pediatrician who has
received international honors for his
work in cross-cultural and integrative
medicine
greg is a graduate of carleton college
harvard divinity school and the
university of minnesota medical school
from 2002 to 2008 dr platnikov served as
an associate professor at cale
university school of medicine where he
studied research and taught the campbell
herbal medicine tradition
in japan he was active in east-west
medical integration issues with the
japanese society of oriental medicine
national geographic and the word world
health organization
he is the recipient of several
international awards for research and
teaching as well as the early career
distinguished achievement award from the
university of minnesota medical school
dr platnikov is well known for his work
in interventional nutrition herbal
medicines and spirituality and clinical
care
he has additional training as a hospital
chaplain in medical acupuncture and mind
body skills and as a practitioner of
traditional east asian medicine
he is co-author of the book trust your
gut
and author of 22 textbook chapters and
more than 50 first author articles in
the medical literature including several
in japanese
in 2003
his 2003 article on vitamin d and
chronic pain is one of the most highly
cited articles in the history of the
mayo clinic proceedings
dr platnikov serves an as an integrative
medicine physician at the penny george
institute for health and healing and as
a senior consultant at the center for
healthcare innovation allina healthcare
in minneapolis minnesota
he also serves as a co-editor of the new
journal global advances in health and
medicine
dr platnikov will be taking questions to
type a question simply click on the
green question
and answer button in the lower left
corner of your screen you can do this at
any time during the webinar and dr
potnikov will read and respond them
respond to them at the end of the
presentation
so at this time i will turn the webinar
over to dr platnikov
great well thank you allison thank you
all for
joining me this morning or this
afternoon depending on where you are
the topic is the clinical utility of the
dihydroxy vitamin d the 125 dihydroxy
vitamin d
and
this is turned out to be something
that's really actually
quite hot and so i'm very interested in
sharing with you um the practical
implications
of this but first let me start and give
a disclosure
no off-label use no investigational use
and that i am receiving an honorarium
for doing this
in addition i want to note in the nine
case studies that i'll present
each has been drawn from the
peer-reviewed medical literature
and has already gone through irb
approval and so therefore i will not be
violating my patients
privacy and presenting um
their particular stories without irp
approval
so let's go ahead and get started first
of all the 125 dihydroxy vitamin d you
think about wasting is this about
something about as rare as a polar bear
in london
well in fact actually
this is actually turned out to be a very
important aspect of
advanced
medical practice and
in my particular
practice for example i only accept the
physician referrals for the most complex
patients
mystery illness and therefore having
this tool and this understanding has
been crucial
in
both diagnosis and treatment of a number
of patients that i work with
but when it comes to vitamin d related
issues
it may be like most people who just kind
of throw up their hands and say oh my
god this is so complex
and in fact actually um
one could get lost in vocabulary and a
variety of things so my aim today is to
make is to
bring some calm and and have a logical
flow
so that you can feel comfortable in
understanding uh vitamin d testing and
and its applications and particularly
the use of the 125 dihydroxy vitamin d
and its relationship to testing for 25
hydroxy vitamin d
in doing so i'm going to want to address
um
these clinical areas
hypercalcemia which by far and away is
most important
we will also address hypocalcemia and
the use of the 125
in
normal calcimia
in addition we will address the issue
about monitoring treatment and therapies
with use of
this
testing so let's go ahead and begin and
with
oops
fail to connect to server please click
the refresh button below
okay so a little technical glitch and
we should be okay and here we go all
right so some key points that that
everyone needs to know
one is that the 125 dihydroxy vitamin d
is the
activated form it is the hormone
and that binds the vitamin d receptor
found in numerous tissues throughout the
body
however the 125 dihydroxy vitamin d test
is not the measure of vitamin d status
and this is very important sometimes
people accidentally order this test when
they really should be ordering the 25
hydroxy vitamin d test
part of the reasons for this is that the
half-life of this hormone is about four
to six hours
and its concentration is just
um it's a thousand times less than that
of the 25 hydroxy vitamin d
this also points out the fact that
getting
good accurate measurements has been a
technical challenge
and so the recent breakthroughs and now
the availability of fda approved testing
represents a remarkable new era in
vitamin d
so let's review
on the left side of the screen is
something taken from the nether series
and so this is something that people
like myself or in med school in the
1980s
would have learned and that is you know
if we follow things here
we've got you know
sunlight
activating the 7d hydro cholesterol
found in our skin
that
in the presence of heat then it becomes
vitamin d
3 the cholecalciferol
the same thing found in the supermarket
shelves
it can um then go on to liver becoming
um the 25
dihydroxy vitamin d
um and then going on to kidney where in
the proximal tubule the 125 dihydroxy
vitamin
d
would be produced
and that still is true
the nuances
since then include
issues about having a vitamin d receptor
and where it is found in its activity
and its polymorphisms
the use of the sip
p450 system and the roles that it plays
in activating and deactivating
vitamin d
and then additional information
that the future
is going to involve also understanding
what exactly is the role of vitamin d
binding protein
we won't be addressing that today um but
i do want to kind of bring you up to
date what where things are so this slide
here
kind of is a nice way of bringing it all
together
so upper left hand corner the 7d
hydrocholesterol found in the skin
in the presence of ultraviolet
b that is approximately 300 nanometer
wavelength
you can get pre-vitamin d that in the
presence of heat or isomerize and become
what we know as vitamin d3
this is
known as
cholecalciferol
which is vitamin d or vitamin d3
available over the counter
widely
and what would be found in supplemented
milk
etc
um or ergo calciferol
which is
actually um derived from mushrooms
or gastro in the cell wall of fungi when
exposed to ultraviolet b goes from
ergosterol to ergocalciferol vitamin d2
which has a shorter half-life than d3
and has different metabolic products and
so their nuances in the use of ergo
calciferon colic calciferon
the important point here is and the next
step is um
is the
the
2r1
found in the liver
we get the production of calcidiol
circulating and then going through sip
27 and b1 it becomes activated vitamin d
calcitriol
now the sip 27b1 is also known as the
one alpha hydroxylase
and that is found in great
concentrations in the proximal tubule of
the kidneys
however it's been found also to been
demonstrated throughout the body
including
parathyroid
and immune cells
muscle cells
and widely distributed
and because
the calcium trial is actually a hormone
it binds the super family nuclear
receptors in which the vitamin d
receptor is one
and that has a great implications
um
for health and we'll talk we'll continue
talking about that
so here's a clinical pearl
low vitamin d
that is the 25 hydroxy vitamin d that
can be measured
means uh low ionized calcium
low ionized calcium means increased pth
increased pth means increase 125
dihydroxy vitamin d
and so therefore you have this very
interesting pattern
25 hydroxy vitamin d deficiency
at times can equal a 125 dihydroxy
elevation
likewise
in
um vitamin over-the-counter vitamin d
toxicity that is ex
when one has exceptionally high levels
of the 25 hydroxy vitamin d
one could actually have profoundly low
levels of the 125.
so there really is no correlation
whatsoever between the two
um that is you can't plot out a linear
relationship it's all over the map
the one thing we do know is that the 125
does increase during pregnancy and
actual significance
that is not fully understood
next let's go ahead and take a look at
the whole
circle here
key point is this is what has been been
measured
um
and
uh by classic vitamin d
we talked about the sip 27b1 being
activating it and getting it 125
dihydroxy vitamin d
please note that parathyroid hormone
um will actually feed back and regulate
the sip 27 b1 the one alpha
it also feed back and address this issue
of
24a1 which is the breakdown
enzyme
and so parathyroid
this is a feedback loop
between these
additionally um we will address the
issue about the fibro fiber fiber blast
growth
factor 23 fgf23
which has another feedback loop and
we'll come back to that a little bit
later
but just the key point here to remember
a simple point is
125 dihydroxy vitamin d production is
tightly regulated
and so it's under very close control
key point um
please keep that in mind as we talk
about cases
so
as clinicians here's what people need to
understand
and this is what exactly i would be
teaching in medical school this class
inpatient hypercalcemia is almost always
due to malignancy
and so the differential diagnosis for an
inpatient with high calcium levels
could include
bone breakdown due to metastatic cancer
multiple myeloma
elevated parathyroid hormone which we do
to primary
hyperparathyroidism
or ectopic production
parathyroid hormone
most often would be associated with
malignancies but there are other
conditions as well
again production of the parathyroid
hormone related protein
that is malignancy related
um you can have excessive
supplementation of vitamin d and that
can include
unintentional through
tube feedings or
other unintentional
problems
or you can have actual
excessive 125 dihydroxy vitamin d
production
and
for
outpatient hypercalcemia
here are the things that i always have
to consider number one primary
hyperparathyroidism
number two vitamin d intoxication
through excessive intake
and then
number three granulomatous diseases such
as sarcoid or histo
in fact
there are literally dozens of
granulomatous diseases that can be
related to
high
hyper calcimia malignancy of course an
outpatient issue um
acromegaly or excessive growth hormone
and then there are actually about 30
different conditions which are
associated with
um
hypercalcemia and so it can include
different inflammatory conditions
infectious conditions um as we'll see
even polymorphism polymorphisms and sip
enzymes
so
and i have here saying
last section didn't succeed please try
again
let's try again here
first case
okay our first case is a 67 year old
previously healthy male in fact as
healthy as can be
developed
polyuria unsteady gait dizziness
confusion dehydration
brought to the emergency room
uh he's found being acute renal failure
a creatinine 4.9
is calcium is sky high is 16.3
okay here we think about what is our
differential diagnosis we need to think
you know primarily let's take a look at
number one parathyroid hormone it comes
back high
okay well we have a good explanation for
this
let's resuscitate him and let's get an
ultrasound of his parathyroid and lo and
behold there is a mass
so a treatment of course in this case
after resuscitation is surgery needs to
have the mass removed
and lo and behold his parathyroid
hormone goes down as it's removed
and his his renal failure resolves
his pth is normal
and we've got successful resolution of a
commonly seen condition primary
hyperparathyroidism
now nuance
wait a second his calcium is still high
11.1
what now
well that's when we go back to our
different differential diagnosis and
consider okay is it primary
hyperparathyroidism no it's been treated
is it vitamin d intoxication well let's
get a 25 hydroxy vitamin d level is it
perineoplastic or is it due to
other conditions
and let's get a 125 dihydropsea vitamin
d as well
the results are
that his parathyroid hormone-related
protein is normal
as dihydroxy vitamin d is sky high at
greater than 200
well
what now
so let's go back to our differential
diagnosis
is it sarcoid or other granulomatous
disease
is it a malignancy is it acromegaly is
it some other condition such as
inflammatory or infectious
well uh common things being common in
previously healthy
people it's more likely to be sarcoid
granulomatous or some inflammatory
condition
so
go hunting for this
and
click to the next
slide here
so there's no evidence of any
granulomatous disease on exam um no
suggestion to main bone mats
no suggestion of really having growth
hormone issues so looking for malignancy
will do things such as pep scanning or
cts or elsewhere
and lo and behold
he's found to have a large b cell
lymphoma in his spleen
and actually looking for with
immunoreactive agents you can actually
demonstrate that he's got the one alpha
hydroxylase
um present in
this lymphoma and so therefore you have
extra renal
and
unphysiologic or
outside of normal parameters production
of the dihydroxy vitamin d
and so hence uh having this
test is actually very very helpful
in
defining
cases so let's move on to a second case
here's a 65 year old male okay
and he is found be vitamin d deficient
how many people have seen this is this
is common worldwide now as more and more
people are being tested and found being
deficient deficiency is certainly a
worldwide issue
easy enough to treat
and he's actually given a prescription
dose for ergocalciferol
50 000 international units
um once or twice a week
for several months
repeat
testing became important as he became
symptomatic
again issues like headache fatigue
nausea diarrhea
polyuria
and
with becoming symptomatic check his
calcium and lo and behold
14.1
quite high
is this a case of iatrogenic vitamin d
toxicity
how can we tell
well
that's what we really become important
so obviously we're going to stop any
kind of supplemental vitamin d
and
go through our differential diagnosis
is it primary hyperparathyroidism is it
vitamin d intoxication
granulomatism malignancy acromegaly or
the others
so
and that's where you really have to know
about the sequencing of ordering
parathyroid hormone the 25 hydroxy d
and then most often people maybe get
together
looking for perineoplastic or
granulomatous depending on clinical
situation whether you want to get the
125 alone or when you get it with the
pth related protein
in this case uh we'll follow that order
his pth comes back normal
so his high calcium is not due to
the primary
hyperparathyroidism his vitamin d comes
back to normal so in fact his
prescription vitamin d was is not a
cause of this this is not an iatrogenic
issue it's an issue that became actually
unblinded or actually appeared because
of this treatment
his related protein is normal okay rules
out some type of malignancy
and his 125 dihydroxy is elevated
okay all right crucial for solving this
case is this lab value
so we have go hunting why is it is it
granulomatism malignancy or elsewhere
just x-ray ct or negative a common lab
test for sarcoid called angio-intensive
converting enzyme
ace is suggestive and not definitive and
ace
levels
correlate but are not
not definitive in many cases you have
normal levels with sarcoid
so we don't have a full picture here
it's a little bit ambiguous what is the
next step
so in this case
whether it's granulomatous or whether
it's kind of inflammatory
treatment is very reasonable to go ahead
and treat with prednisone and they did
and
and lo and behold is 125 normalized
and
so they continue for a while stopped
and then it comes the hypercalcemia
comes back
okay that's when you have to begin then
a further
evaluation
an intense splenic uptake is found
is this another lymphoma well it's kind
of uh the treatment in either
whether or not it's treatment
splenectomy
and um actually it's found to have
sarcoid in the spleen
and so either you know it's in the first
case you have the lymphoma limit to the
spleen second case you have a sarcoid
limit to the spleen and it shows that
that
clinical
evaluation becomes really really really
important laboratory testing is so
important because things can be hidden
and unexpected
so
let's uh go on to the next case then
we're clicking here and
a third common situation um is that of
chronic kidney disease
and i became very sensitized this back
in med school in the 1980s when
i was
working in pediatric nephrology and
where renal osteodystrophy had in the
days really before we had a lot of
pediatric kidney transplants for chronic
kidney disease
these children of growing developing
children developed in reno
osteodystrophy and became greatly
distorted in
in bones height
and
it was an incredible
change that
completely destroyed now the appearance
but destroyed their ability to fully
function and participate in life
major major major issue
um and um we can talk about that a
little bit more in this particular case
where it's not a child at all it's an 81
year old and this is probably much more
frequently seen in people's practice
that is
someone with
diabetic nephropathy who's on dialysis
and
with
dialysis it was discovery that
that the vitamin d
receptor is found on the parathyroid
hormone a parathyroid
gland itself
meant that activated vitamin d
regulate parathyroid hormone and this is
where the renal osteodystrophy issue
became important where people could then
treat with
either activated vitamin d
or vitamin d analogues
or
pro
drugs such as alpha calcium diox
and actually
uh prevent renal osteodystrophy issues
or
bone significant bone losses
this has been a big breakthrough because
there's also significantly reduced
mortality um
this treatment and so there's great
value in it
and of course it needs to be monitored
in this 81 year old he was having
progressive
hypercalcemia
so you stop the of course the treatment
with the analog
and it progressed and he develops
fatigue anorexia insomnia
hmm
what's going on it's got examination is
normal routine labs are normal
so let's go through our differential
diagnosis is it primary
hyperparathyroidism
is he have excessive vitamin d intake or
excessive calcium intake
or does he have increased 125 dihydrocd
so we go through
the
the labs pth is normal
it's kind of got a low normal 25 hydroxy
kind of classic people renal disease
his related protein is less than one so
it doesn't and
is 125
is it the upper edge of normal at 55.
hmm
well what do we do now and it doesn't
fit what we're talking about um
well it's just x-rays normal
his ace is borderline again it's kind of
not really helpful
so the next step
well
and this raises an important point
the laboratory results for calcium you
have clear hypercalcemia
um the results of the 125 dihydroxyde
are important here
in patients with chronic kidney disease
you do not expect to have elevated
levels or even high normal levels of 125
dihydroxy vitamin d
the kidney is just not there
the
proximal institute of tubules are just
not going to be producing
the 125
and so you can even have a quote normal
level
um
and
and and that would be considered
relatively high
and so therefore
um based on this and we still have to go
through than the differential diagnosis
is it sarcoid is it
other granulomatous disease is it
lymphoma or other malignancies is it
growth hormone excess or other things
such as
in different inflammatory diseases or
rare infectious diseases
so
you can tell why getting a good and
valid and accurate measurement of the
125 is so important in these patients
with
chronic kidney disease it's is crucial
because the next steps are quite
invasive
um you know or very expensive or
whole body ct pet scanning
skin biopsies bone marrow biopsies
all invasive all expensive and want to
be
very sure that these next steps are
absolutely
indicated so in this case
we're able to go to skin biopsy and it
showed non-cascading granulomas with
multinucleated giant cells
classic
for sarcoid
so a treatment do we give prednisone
or not
so obviously before giving prednisone as
a potent steroid
and if you're going to be treating
sarcoid
you treat with fairly high doses for
long periods of time so it's a very
important decision you have to be very
clear on next steps
uh for this
and and so in this case
they said well amount of sarcoid kind of
resolves on its own the hypercalcemia
wasn't so
excessive
we're closely monitoring him since he's
getting dialysis three times a week so
it's monitor symptoms let's monitor a
physical exam let's monitor his calcium
let's use the vitamin d3 cautiously
and we'll monitor is 125.
these last two points are really crucial
sarcoid is a fairly common disease
and
vitamin d status is very important we do
not want
people to
have low vitamin d levels as the 25
hydroxy d
because of a couple reasons
number one
is that
low levels um
mean that there's going to be low 125
dihydroxy vitamin d and therefore all
the hormonal issues related to the
vitamin d receptor activation and gene
regulation
in multiple tissues throughout the body
becomes very important
second
it appears that
in many conditions that
vitamin d
plays a significant role
in
modulating immune response and the like
and so
so there's
biological plausibility even if there
aren't randomized controlled
and
third is that
when giving people uh
with a sarcoid vitamin d
you want to make sure that you're not
actually kind of creating a
situation of excessive 125
and so for all those people on with
sarcoid who or history of sarcoid who
are receiving vitamin d
you need to
monitoring is very important
of the vitamin d level and the dihydroxy
vitamin d
so that we can avoid
hypercalcemic situations
hypercalcemia is not only a pleasant
physiological experience for people with
nausea and diarrhea and headache and
fatigue
but with advanced levels and mental
status changes
profound dehydration
and certainly it can be quite life
threatening
so
and with doing this
these physicians were able to avoid
using prednisone in this patient and
but 16 months later it became clear that
he really needed it
and that's where that monitoring the 125
really became very important
okay
another case
50 year old female hypercalcemia
not so bad 10.9 her she's got a normal
25 hydroxy d her pth is
low
she's got no related protein
and her 125 is guy high
okay
what might be going on here
well in fact um
going through things the embaymed
most frequently seen problems are like
granulomatous disease um brutal
malignancy
then what else do you need to consider
well in fact actually
parathyroid hormone 125 and
issues around growth hormone
are all interconnected with insulin-like
growth factor one
so it is now becoming apparent that
since we can also measure these then we
can actually then go and further define
conditions of hypercalcemia that have
been well understood before
in this case she had very high
insulin-like growth factor
one
very high growth hormone so we have to
go hunting for pituitary tumor and lo
and behold she has one by mri
the treatment of
choice here of course is surgical
resection and transfernoidal
route
which
is his head presents his own technical
challenges but it is quite doable
the tumor is not excessively large and
so it's accessible
and
and surgeon reports a complete reception
so postoperatively we can measure these
things to see well how well is this
really true calcium is normal igf-1 is
normal growth hormone's normal and the
dihydroxy is normal
we have a cure
okay this is great
so celebration let's do a similar case
another uh woman
52 she's got mild hypercalcemia it's got
low pth normal 25oh
memory delayed protein is normal
and her dihydroxy's high normal 66 but
her physical exam has visual field cuts
and that is kind of loss of capacity c
areas and that is classic for
a pituitary tumor and
heating or kind of encroaching upon
uh
nerves
optic nerves
so we do need to get an mri on her
and
i need to consider
this and so in fact actually the mri was
done first she had a three centimeter
fairly large invasive pituitary and
macroadenoma and with related
mark to elevations and
growth factor and
insulin-like growth factor and growth
hormone
so this combination um you see where
it's all connected now
reception of something this large is
quite complicated because of location
and so we need to monitor of course uh
postoperatively
so
postoperatively your calcium is still
high and
bouncing between 10 1 and 11 1.
her insulin like growth factor is still
high
quite high at 440. her growth hormone
has come down but is still high from at
12.8 and her dihydroxy has gone from 66
upper limit of normal to actually a high
at 81.
this is not a cure and this is someone
who needs um
close monitoring so
how are we going to monitor well
certainly the 125 dihydroxy is going to
be important to a factor because
of
excessive calcium and
and excessive
production of
activation of all the vitamin d
receptors
so at this point then it becomes uh
important to say well okay then what
else can we do
and
that is where um
the future of treatment cell will be
taking place that there are a variety of
interventions to try to suppress things
at this time
okay
so and it's confirmed that this patient
had residue and therefore needs
monitoring
okay
what is another common situation okay
now we're
we're going to be
uh talk about kind of kidney stones here
again worldwide is a huge huge huge huge
uh
incidence and most often is
things related to calcium oxalate and
current treatments include uh use of
vitamin b6
low oxalate diets
vitamin c
very interesting research going on about
use of probiotics
we're going to go a different direction
here
so this is kind of a
interesting case because this is a young
person 24 year old guy who has had six
years
of frequent kidney stones
it's very clear that he's got
hypercalciuria so he's got lots of
calcium being released into his urine
and he also has hypercalcemia
but his pth is
low
his vitamin d is normal and his
dihydroxy is high
well here's where we need to go through
that differential diagnosis again and so
is it granulomatous is it malignancy is
it acromegaly
is it something else
inflammatory or infectious and very kind
more rare
conditions
well in fact actually
extensive evaluation showed that he
actually had reduced function of his sip
24a1
enzyme
in a late onset and so this is uh
very interesting so let me return then
to remind you
where the sip enzymes
go
so we've been talking about sip 27b1 as
the activating enzyme to take
the 25 hydroxy vitamin d to the
activated vitamin d the 125
and
but also important is the breakdown of
these
uh as part of the whole regulatory
system that's the sip 24a1
is involved in breakdown
so we as we discover more and more
polymorphisms polymorphisms um
um for
sip enzymes we discover that if one has
a profoundly low functioning
sib 24a1 then chances are we can have
high levels
it's biologically plausible and so that
would be the story in this case
now people are looking at
sip 24 a1 inhibitors
or activators
to help
with these polymorphisms it's a very
exciting area future research
applicable to many things not just
kidney stones but also
cancer etc
okay
all right we've done six cases so far um
and i'm glad people are sending in
questions i look forward i'm hoping this
is provocative and i'm hoping that
you're saying that the clinical
reasoning and the utility
um we've been talking about
hypercalcemia
um and
um
and so let's take a look and consider
other cases the hypercalcemia so far
has been in
non-malignancy cases so let's talk about
malignancy
this is a 57 year old guy with left
flank pain
anorexia
23 kilos of weight loss over two months
he's sick
cat scanning over the area of pain shows
that he's got a large mass in his left
kidney
and he's got retroperitoneal lymph nodes
this is some kind of malignancy
biopsy done shows that he's got a renal
cell carcinoma this is a bad diagnosis
so we're going to do everything can
best hope is surgical resection
but preoperative evaluation
finds him being nauseous he's attributed
to morphine he's got low sodium he's got
high glucose and he's hypercalcemic
with a relatively normal albumin
so
nausea could certainly be due to the
hypercalcemia
why is he hypercalcemic and if he is
hypercalcemic going into surgery
how significant
might this be it can certainly
cause intraoperative problems
so in fact let's go through
again our differential diagnosis and
what are labs we're going to get well
first the pth second to 25 oh
then the relayed protein
we can consider bone scans about
metastases or other issues and we get a
125
level
and so going through these the pth is
low
25oh is normal
the relay protein is normal
and his 125 is quite high
going into surgery this is this is
important to know we need to find out
what might be going on here or at least
we need to um
pre-operatively kind of counterbalance
so that calcium
excess is not going to
be a problem during surgery
so
able to get his calcium down to 10.6
okay so not excessively high
and
he so he undergoes
surgery corrective surgery um it's
actually a kind of extensive surgery
and
postoperatively his 125 comes down to 24
from 118 and his calcium comes down to
normal
so actually surgery was a treatment of
choice for this hypercalcemia
and so looking at pathology he actually
had a very unusual tumor this divergent
differentiation between squamous and
sarcomatoid appearance of the renal cell
carcinoma
and if one looks in the literature one
can find many cases actually of
hypercalcemia suppressed pth and normal
parathyroid hormone-related protein
but know that because 125 testing has
not
been readily or easily available
case studies are not reporting on this
and so in fact having this
new measurement allows us to advance
knowledge
of malignancies and so this is a a area
of
potential
great interest in the future to help us
better understand
malignancy and
an optimal treatment
okay so
hypercalcemia we've done seven cases um
i did talk about that we were talking
about hypocalcemia
and normal calcimia for the 125.
and so um our next case is something you
say
oh yes ricketts
this is a
very important issue these days as
actually worldwide the incidence of
ricketts has become really um
quite increased a recent
headline london newspaper talked about a
significant and
remarkable increase in rickets in the uk
uh in children and so it's something we
must all be aware of that must uh
and must help get the word out on
and this case actually comes from a
country where ricketts
or massive increase in rickets led to
national public health campaigns to
ensure that all infants got vitamin d
supplementation
and in fact this case actually comes out
of the supplementation
public health movement
and that is there's a 25 month old
female
she's got disproportionate growth she's
perspiring she's constipated she has
deformed extremities she has walking
difficulties
she's got hair loss
partial alopecia so patchy
she's had convulsions that no one can
explain she's got bone pain she's got
weak muscles
okay clearly there's a child who is
quite ill
so is it rickets
well
um
why we don't know what else might we
find on exam
so
um she's got an open anterior fontanelle
there's the soft spot in front of the
head where her sutures are normal she's
got mild frontal blossoming so that's a
a dysmorphic feature
the apache distribution
and she's got some very interesting
things so at her wrist um
she's got what are called double joints
that's kind of it so it's wide and
there's kind of two bumps right here
relaxing there so double joints
um clear changes um and both the radius
and ulna the two
bones of the forearm that go to the
wrist
he's got a widened
distal metathesis of the fibula now what
this is the fibula is one of the bones
of the lower
portion of the leg it goes into the
ankle
now we all recognize that there's kind
of an ankle bump
on both sides of the ankle
this would be an additional
bump so instead of one um kind of ankle
bumps there are two
clearly an abnormal situation
and then she's got the classic um boeing
of the legacy the x sign
and
so it looks like ricketts ricketts
ricketts ricketts ricketts
until proven otherwise
so
um
but vitamin d is normal
now ricketts is a vitamin d deficiency
level so
we've got some other kind of situation
here
what's going on
you know is it a calcium problem
so let's get calcium and lo and behold
it comes back
low so this is the case then of
hypocalcemic
problems
and does she have an appropriate
response to low calcium and yes her
parathyroid hormone is high
low calcium
high parathyroid hormone
is it dietary is it something else
and so in fact
um let's evaluate this a little bit
further
looking at bone health markers
alkyphosis alkaline phosphatase as a
commonly
measured thing and comes back
sky high
so we also have to then check the 125
dihydroxy it also comes back
quite high
wow this is a complex situation
and in fact actually
what we can say is that this is a
vitamin d
dependency
rickets
type ii
and for this
the treatment of choice is
intravenous calcium
and high-dose calcite trial
the reason for that is that this is a
condition where vitamin d receptor
polymorphism
polymorphisms
exist
and there is a spectrum of vitamin d
polymorphism morphisms
and for this type of
maybe called
vitamin d dependency rickets type ii
the
spectrum exists from
complete
non-responsiveness
to calcitriol activated 125
dihydroxyd
to partial response and so in fact
actually treatment actually is to
increase levels even further
than the already elevated levels
and treatment in this
case this
two-year-old going to three-year-old
three-year-old
after 90 days were able to normalize her
alphas her bone pain is resolved and her
strength is increasing
and actually her
thyroid hormone was able to be
normalized at 120 days
so this then is a child whose
measurement of the 125 dihydroxy vitamin
d led to diagnosis
and
treatment that's within human capacity
and so it has a much more promising
life ahead of her because of this
all right
last case uh for our talk today
osteoporosis
obviously huge issue worldwide and
increasing with
with the aging in the population
so this is a 55 year old gentleman going
to osteoporosis clinic
his dexa that is a measurement of bone
mineral density
his dexa score is quite abnormal
his total right hip t score is minus 3.5
the absolute definition of osteoporosis
is a t score of minus 2.5
so he is like weighing in into this and
he has multiple fractures
despite bisphosphonate treatment
now
he also is experiencing fatigue
weakness weight loss and falls
he's 55.
what's going on his history of chronic
sinusitis but otherwise pretty
unremarkable
what are we going to make to this
well
let's think about um
evaluation of bone disease you know
number one is you know it's kind of
does have normal calcium you have
and uh see you have a normal vitamin d
yep
and there's normal pth yep
huh what else could be going on here
um his creatinine normal is normal so
he's got good kidney function
but his alphas is elevated so
something's going on in the bones
we know and his phosphate
surprisingly is low
and this is a very interesting uh
condition a low phosphate
you see this in
like refeeding disorders and people who
have been starved or people have been
alcoholic
this is a common condition and county
hospitals with homeless people coming in
and
but
you know this is a 55 year old active
employed
a man with kind of
unusual bone history
and so
i have to get the 125 dihydroxy to
actually understand this case
and in this case it comes back as
low
wow
how do we make sense of this
and so this is
um
let me just click to the next slide here
okay so this is clearly hypophosphatemia
case but unusual from what most people
experience in their clinical training
so there are three teaching points
which are
quite reasonable for everyone watching
us to know about
and that is
most cases of hypophosphatemia are
associated with an increase
in 125 dihydroxy vitamin d and that is
because 1.5 dihydroxy vitamin d is there
to increase absorption of phosphate
and so this
this is a very unusual picture for them
to be separate in any way
second point is
that the only explanation for low
phosphate in the blood and a low 125
dihydroxy vitamin d is due to aberrant
production of
the fgf23
the other feedback loop
on the 27 mississippi 27b1 and the
activation of
vitamin d
and the third teaching point is that
excess production of sgf23
is
is due to rare inherited bone conditions
not likely be present in someone at age
55 without prior diagnosis
or occult tumors
and so
in this case we absolutely have to
consider an occult tumor
and so
um but let's go and um
this ftf23 is an important new topic and
so just to know that's an essential
regulator of phosphate homeostasis
language you might see related to it is
that there's a receptor 1c and a
co-receptor
in cloth though
it inhibits reabsorption of phosphate
from the urine so therefore you'd expect
high levels of phosphate to be found
in the urine
and
there's that negative feedback loop it
decreases production of the 125
dihydroxy vitamin d
so the bottom line is it lowers serum
phosphate levels and has to be
considered in
situations of low
phosphate in the blood
okay so let's kind of
take a look here is
the ftf 23
it has a negative feedback loop to sip
27 b1 so therefore that's where you're
going to have the reductions in the 125
dihydroxy of vitamin d
um it also activates
the breakdown enzyme
so you could actually have
um
lower
25 hydroxyd
going along with this as well
and so um we're gonna be seeing more of
that and so if you think about the
nuances
of
of um
of evaluation of bone disease
the 125 and the fgf23 are important ways
of kind of expanding
our capacity to serve
patients
so
in this case of course we'd have to
start him on phosphate and
and have to supplement
the
calcite trial
do a scan for the tumor is kind
and and sinuses light up you get ct he's
got a mass there
and go for biopsy and he's got a
a unusual
nasal tumor hemangioperio pericytoma
like tumor
and so the treatment choice in this case
again is surgical
and remove with removal and
postoperatively
phosphate and the 125 normalize
pain resolves he's able to ambulate
and lo and behold
his bones get better his dexa score
improves with the total t score going
from a very severe
level minus 3.5
to a much more reasonable level minus
1.7
in that which is more closer with
osteopenia
so
testing in this case
led to a very nice diagnosis
resolution and a marked improvement in
quality of life
so as we wrap up here and we will be
taking questions i will continue on as
long as you have time
and interest i'll be here
so quick points
dihydroxy vitamin d is the activated
form it must be considered in
hypercalcemic situations
and it should be considered in
hypocalcemic situations as well
the differential diagnosis we have to
consider in most cases
are
we talk about cancer we talk about
elevated pth parathyroid hormone-related
protein excessive supplementation or
excessive 125 production
an outpatient these are the labs which
are most uh
and the order sequence to go pth 25oh
the relay protein and the 125.
um
diagnosis of hypercalcemia hypocalcemia
and we also saw a diagnosis
of
a neutral bone
disease with normal calcimia
therapeutic use it can be used for
monitoring calcitriol therapy
and it can be used for monitoring
calcium trial status with vitamin d
supplementation in patients with sarcoid
or other granulomatous diseases or
they're at high risk for production of
the 125
dihydroxy vitamin d
and
with that i want to say thank you and we
are now i'm going to open up for
questions and we'll go to the question
answer
board here
and
we can also
do
a laboratory question about laboratory
test offline as well if you want to
email
and just to say that this is really the
this is the purpose of this webinar is
to really talk about the clinical
utility of the 125 dihydroxy vitamin d
so we're going to the questions here
right so the first
question
is
is that
it comes
saying that there are many natural
isomers of 125
uh dihydroxy vitamin d such as 24 25 and
23 25 which as you saw
are breakdown products in some cases the
2425 concentration is higher than the
125 concentration
how does it impact diagnosis and is the
determination of these isomers important
okay well thank you for this question
let me go back and
and
look at
i want to show you a
slide
here just a second
okay
so um here is where we're talking about
um
the different isomers um we've got the
twenty three twenty five the one twenty
four twenty five
you've got um um
uh put what
we've got um
a variety of things which um
all of which
can be measured and all of which if your
goal is to understand the 125
that's why um as you've identified a
very important technical issue
in um in measurement and that's why
it's kind of so much effort has gone
into find something
with accurate measurement uh
that presumably is a thousand times less
concentrated than the 25 hydroxy vitamin
d
but you can see that there are multiple
isomers that you don't want to be
measuring
and uh and so that's
why um
you want to take a look at what your
laboratory tests can do
question also you raised um was how does
that impact diagnosis and determination
of these important
my sense is that clinically speaking
measurement of these
plays no significant
role in current clinical practice
um you do not want to be measuring these
accidentally and getting false numbers
for your 125 dihydroxy vitamin d
um
okay next question
and it comes from the university of
washington
um
the question is
um it's i'm trying to
translate the english here is um the
thought of taking vitamin d
supplementation with calcium will
enhance the effect of vitamin d
um and actually vitamin d
the causality issue here is that vitamin
d is related to calcium absorption
from
oral sources
and to recognize that uh as demonstrated
um
um
um
having seen your moment uh the our
researcher friend at university of
nebraska um demonstrate that going from
a serum level of 20 nanograms per ml to
30 nanograms per ml increases calcium
absorption by 65 percent
um and calcium isn't going to
necessarily play a huge role um in
other effects of vitamin d as the 125
dihydroxy vitamin
d
um but obviously the two of them work
together and magnesium and multiple
other factors play a role
and uh and
but the binder
to the vitamin d receptor through which
all actions are mediated
is the 125 dihydroxy vitamin d and that
is under very tight regulation
including calcium
levels and so that's how they all
intersect
third question here from the university
of toronto
most labs measure the
25 hydroxy vitamin d using an
immunoassay which measures both d2 and
d3 in equal amounts
are there situations where you would
need to differentiate dietary versus
endogenous derived forms
such as to monitor prescription
supplements
should clinicians be aware of which
methods are used in the lab
okay so this is uh
this takes us out of the 125 dihydroxy
vitamin d and into the 25 hydroxy
vitamin d measurement
and
clinically what counts
um is
the measurement of total 25 hydroxy
vitamin d
um
that accounts for and
and that would be um going along with
vitamin d3
um
in a extremely small percent cases you
know less than one percent of cases
would one ever
you know consider there being any value
to a measurement of vitamin d2
and because and so
in my experience
what counts is total
25 hydroxy vitamin d
and
and the
idea of getting d2 and d3 measurements
is nothing more than clutter
to
complicate people's lives
you measure
response and absorption through
improvement in these um
and the 25 hydroxy vitamin d measurement
and if you are not
if you do not have a good response
to an appropriate dosing or what you
think appropriate dosing you have to
think of is it the right dose
is it being absorbed what's the
differential diagnosis for
fat soluble nutrient malabsorption you
need to get a vitamin a level as well
do you have
changes in gut wall integrity effect
absorption due to changes in pancreatic
digestive enzyme production and the like
the differential diagnosis is long but
clinically what counts is total 25
hydroxy vitamin d
next question
also from university of toronto
the c3 epimere neonates can interfere
with some methods to measure vitamin d
is your clinical utility for the c3
epimer in neonates
and
i'm sorry i do not know enough to be
able to answer that
question
what i do know
is that um
is that there is a difference between
the use of the fda approved
clia diagnostic
instrumentation for testing for
total vitamin d and use of hplc
double mass spec
as uh documented uh by bruce hollis and
others in the medical literature
um that uh there are three problems with
the hplc uh
double mass spec number one is
technically it's it's extremely
difficult and we saw one national lab
testing company have to uh recall
tens of thousands of uh testings and
because of of violations and and
standard testing procedures and having
wildly inaccurate
values being reported to clinicians
second is the hplc
double mass spec also
captures many many many forms of vitamin
d
outside of the ones that are
biologically active as currently
understood
and so therefore using
radial immunoassay or clia
other advanced you know assays that
don't require radioactivity um are
much more helpful
perhaps c3 epimer plays a role
in things i'm i can't answer that more
directly i apologize
next question does the type of
supplementation matter for example gummy
bears tablets oil tablets are they
different in
efficacy of the supplementation
and what are thoughts in cod liver oil
supplementation
so thank you for this question this is
um obviously clinically very important
in guiding patients
so number one is that
you know vitamin d is vitamin d is
vitamin d
however
the different products vary
significantly by
what
um excipients they are combined with and
what forms they they come in
so
what has me concerned is uh
it is kind of are people reactive to
other ingredients in it
for example
corn is found in a lot of products
and we can
document that a number of people have
adverse food reactivity to corn relate
products
second obviously people are aware of
gluten and gluten sensitivity issues
and they exist in some products
third
use of titanium dioxide and other things
can also precipitate reactivity in
people
and fourth i'm using things like um
drops uh d-drops for example um
uh are based in a coconut oil um
base and so
people can some people can be reactive
to
coconut
what counts in terms of absorption is
really based on digestion
and uptake issues and
digestion can vary depending upon
whether there's uh acor hydra or
functional a-chlorhydria with use of
of um
proton pump inhibitors or other acid
blocking medications
there can be disruptions and gut wall
integrity and effect
absorption
there can be
production difficulties or physical
blockage of issues
related
to pancreatic digestive enzyme
production or release as well as bile
production or release can all play
roles in this
and so
big thing is
just monitoring how is this person
responding they appear to be responding
appropriately or inappropriately if
they're not getting good clinical
response is it due to
underdosing for bmi or is it male
absorption issue or adverse food
reactivity issue
cod liver oil
of course is where
quote the anti-rekidic
component was found and for treatment of
rickets
and
very interesting history
from cod liver oil people were looking
at was the vitamin a responsible for
treating rickets and they said no
and they found this anti-kidney factor
and because
vitamin b and vitamin c were already
taken it was called vitamin d and that's
where we get our vitamin d
issue from so vitamin d is present in
cod liver oil
however the reason i don't recommend cod
liver oil
for people in general is because it
actually has high levels of vitamin a
pre and i would much rather have people
take pre-vitamin a that's found in the
carotenoids
which are over 600 types
found in colored vegetables and the like
and then by giving pre-vitamin a it
allows the body to decide on its own how
much vitamin a to produce
there it's probably hard to get vitamin
a toxicity from cod liver oil but given
the relationship that has been published
in pure literature
about vitamin a
being associated with actually
kind of an
anti-bone mineral density effect
i would much rather see people do fish
oil or other products
to get long-chain omega-3 fatty acids if
they do not have them in their diet
and to consider other sources
for um
for both vitamin d and vitamin a
and our
our um
last question
do you see the same type from marshall
university school of medicine thank you
do you see the same types of trends in
the pediatric population
and in the pediatric population
um there are
three areas i think is really important
to be aware of
number one is that the worldwide
incidence
of vitamin d deficiency in women of
childbearing age is incredibly high
second
issue is that vitamin d deficiency
during pregnancy has significant and is
associated
uh with significant adverse impacts on
both maternal and fetal health and
neonatal health
and
third
issue about this is that
it appears that prenatal vitamins
do not provide nearly enough vitamin d
to reach
the desired levels for 97.5 percent of
the north american population
this is a this
comes from our data
at the illini health
study i led
where we measured vitamin d levels in 13
500
health system employees
in two sequential years and correlate
those with a reported vitamin d intake
and i can tell you that
that vitamin d status
needs to be measured because you cannot
guarantee a reasonable vitamin d level
in
in women of child-bearing age by taking
a prenatal vitamin or a multivitamin
now
issues in pediatric population we need
to be aware of is
is that one can have
vitamin d deficiency in the neonatal
period
and that can be related to
idiopathic hypocalcemia
this kind of hype which can be related
to seizure
issues as well as a dilated
cardiomyopathy
the response to that is vitamin d and
calcium
second thing is is that in a study i
led in the city of monterey mexico where
we piggybacked
vitamin d
testing
on top of a
study looking at
iron deficiency and anemia in children
of
grade school children we found a huge
incidence of low vitamin d
profoundly low vitamin d in many
children
and so how could this be existing in
mexico sunny country
the thing is that kids are more and more
kids around the world are tied to the
computers or to other things that
they're you know doing their hands
parents might want kids inside for
safety reasons they might be wearing
sunblock um
and so they might not be getting nearly
enough sun exposure for vitamin d
production
additionally in the worldwide growth
in incidence of obesity
is
is has to be noted as well
the larger the bmi the more
sun exposure one needs to reach adequate
vitamin d levels
the
way you think about that is in a fat
soluble
nutrient you have to look at the volume
of distribution
so the larger the tank the more you need
to fill to get to the same level
and so bmi greater than 30 is a
significant risk factor for low vitamin
d
um
and
we're seeing in multiple look uh things
in sports with um
stress fractures uh and like um
vitamin d is playing a significant issue
and so we in a pediatric population we
cannot presume that children have normal
vitamin d levels
that's why
i strongly believe in
measurement
of these and certainly any child who has
requirements for
any kind prescription drug um
certainly i i believe and this i'm
speaking from opinion and bias
but
deserves a vitamin d level
and uh and monitoring because
um dose
does not count
the only thing that matters is the
vitamin d level achieved and that um
we can only understand
by doing an actual measurement
it's like no different than measuring a
cholesterol you can't look at someone
know the cholesterol level or
they're looking at tsh or um you just
can't really know and so that's why i
also want monitoring is important just
like we monitor warfarin and with the
inr or digoxin levels or cyclosporine
levels
you know dosing varies
first in person one size does not fit
all we've got the technology it's
rational
use
is for monitoring to ensure
neither overdosing or under dosing
and i see that we that is the last of
the questions
if you have additional questions feel
free to
contact the organizers of this webinar i
appreciate your time and attention i
hope i've been helpful and provocative
and i hope you understand
when to get a 25 oh and when to get a
125 dihydroxy
vitamin d level
thank you all very much and have a good
day